*Clapping in sync with color changes*
Pewds: Meme Review
*More clapping in sync with color changes*
Pewds: MEME REVIEW!
Pewds: Meme Review! YouTube's favorite show...
ever
Last week we hit trending, thank you guys so much for all the support
OoOooOhHHBOI
Do we have a lot of spicy memes for this week's
meme. review.
Last week we reviewed Petting Dog meme
haha
I'm petting a dog (yes you are Pewds)
and it's many predecessors.
You guys posted some as well
You joined in on the meme. Hi doggie.
Hey look. It's me
Zootopia meme or Zootopia pro-life meme
OR
Zootopia I will survive
AnOtHeR wEb CoMiC mEmE
Have you watched Zootopia? (no)
Me neither, but it was about a bunny and a fox and someone said to themselves,(NO)
"Hey, I'm gonna make my own version a comic of that stor- Disney story about the fox and the bunny" (NOOOO)
"talking about complex relationship issues such as" (pewds stop)
"pregnancy and whether you should have an abortion or not!" ✞✞✞ (why pewds)
Now this meme got a lot of attention
mainly for the fact of the abzurd abzurb abzerdity abzurbit abzerbity
[robotic voice] Absurdity
For three different reasons. Number one
Zootopia. Number two, a bunny and a fox fucking. (oh god)  Number three, the extremely ✞✞✞✞✞
(<--wth is with the crosses being there?)
over-exaggerated panels. The emotions that they've the artist really captured in this fan
fiction, is quite something so you can easily just replace the text with pretty much anything
and it will just feel off
"I cannot live another day without air conditioning!"
"It says tomorrow's gonna be hotter." Good meme!
"They both weigh the same, Nick!"
"They are both a kilogram."
"But, steel is heavier than fEaThErS." (ur right)
It's actually true. I don't see how people struggle with this mind thought prog thing(?).
Steel is heavier than feathers everyone knows that.
Because it has this...
bigger density.
"You know... Traps are gay."
Look. I posted this one look at that everybody
I am funny and relevant. I post- I post relevant memes
Please validate me. Please. :'(
We have the One Punch Man
We have the "Silly rabbit! Trix are for kids!"
Everyone knows that. we have there everything that we know and love is reducible to the observe acts of chemicals
We have the "Everything that we know and love is reducible to the observe acts of chemicals
"And there is therefore no intrinsic value in this material universe!"
"Hypocrite that you are, for you to trust the chemicals in your brain to tell you they are chemicals. All knowledge is
"Ultimately based on that which we cannot prove."  (thats a long ass meme pewds)
"Will you fight? Or will you perish like a dog?"
This of course is based on the Donald Duck meme and Mickey Mouse meme
But it begs really the question
You know people look at love as some sort of strange substance that we can't understand when really you can just break it down in
scientific thing
You know what they say, love is blind.
"I don't understand"
This is - this one is probably my favorite- "I don't understand.. Our family?! Our entire clan?!"
"Why did you kill our parents??"
"To measure my abilities."
Good old..
Naruto
meme
"It's over Anakin. I have the high ground!"
"You underestimate my power!!"(the powa of trending)
"Nick.. Subs, not dubs."
"No! I can't believe you said that!"
"Nick, hear me out."
Really the the the numerous amount of of
Comic strips that can be adapted in-in-in-in this comic. I think is what really makes it so successful.
"Hey, how do you sprint?"
"ALT + F4"
Player Nick has left the game (disconnected by user.)
"You know.. I had to do it to em."
*snicker* So dumb. Hey look,✞
It's the loss meme, everybody! That's how you truly know if a meme has been accepted or not.
Does it have a Loss meme? Then it's not a true meme.
We have, of course, petting dog meme. (yes we are bac)
Fans of this comic (suck D)
Notice themselves that in the very first image the building is the same building as the Seinfeld building.
This begs the question. Was the artist memeing all along? It's a very interesting topic.
NOW I will have to rate it... Not too high. It was amusing for a while.
But I think-I think the adaptations so far that I've seen doesn't really live up to the potential of this meme.
I mean, eeehhhhhhhh look at--look at these facial expressions
Subs not dubs. Can we talk about more important issues such as.. "Pewdiepie doesn't make original content?!"
uhhh so I'm gonna give it a
4.5. I think it can grow to a 5.5 if we see some better adaptations in the future and not this sub-genre yes
Of memes like you know I had to do it to him or Loss
You know and petting dog the meme has so much potential that it doesn't really need to rely on other memes or
Crossover memes to live up to it
I think with with clever adaptations made by the community
We can really lift his meme up and make it stronger, together, as a collective
(A mighty rousing speech there, Pewds)
MOVING. ON. TO. THE. NEXT. MEME.
This is my favorite meme of the week
Which of course is the Doki Doki Literature Club memes.
If you haven't played Doki Doki, click away now.
Not because I don't want to spoil Doki Doki to you, but because Doki Doki Literature Club memes...
It's something that you have to work for, okay. It's a Normie proof meme, it's protected
from Normies because you have to sit through,
Literally two hours of dialogue just to get to the scary part. The people that can laugh at the Doki Doki
memes are the people that worked hard for the Doki Doki memes. We've earned these memes
Okay, we work for them and really that's what all memes are really. It's a it's a secret Club of "haha"
Inside jokes haha. That's funny. I know what that originates from I bet my mom doesn't
Ha ha this meme makes me laugh now. HA HA - now Doki Doki of course was the game that looks cute on the outside
But on the inside it's the complete opposite
What I played, what I expected, what I got. Can you say fictional characters?
I gotta tell you this is pretty terrific
Now, I think what's so great about Doki Doki memes is that each of the four characters
Natsuki, Sayori, Yuri, and Monika.
They all have their own
Individual subset of memes within the Doki Doki memes and-and-and all the subsets are based on their
Personalities and--their per--and their per--and their personal events that happen in Doki Doki. We have Natsuki
Which is the cute tiny little girl! I mean look at that. She's adorable, then you have swole-suki
To contrast
This young
tiny little woman
I just want to say for my own personal record whoever made buff-suki or or swole-suki
You need to die. You need to die and go to heaven straight away
It is god-awful, and I don't ever want to see it the more
I look at it the more the more life gets sucked out of it
I think it's a cursed image
And I think whoever is making it sucks the life out of people and in an attempt to live forever.
Natsuki: "square up thot"
Natsuki, which also is the little edgy character, she's the, she's the tsundere of the group
We have her saying her classic her classic line. Be careful, or you might cut yourself on that edge
Moving on we have Sayori, the main character of Doki Doki, the extremely cute and
childish sort of character
Which is really the pinnacle of this meme you gotta say. "When your childhood friend rejects your confession"
"Guess I'll die."
Sayori forces a smile through an incredibly pained
expression. There were another stock image memes of the 'I want to die' smile face meme
Which makes sense of course because Sayori commits suicide. Monika? This is not a meme
This is just a picture from the game, but reading in after you finish the game it becomes a meme
"You kind of left her hanging this morning, you know?"
Here we have Sayori dabbing, petting dog meme, here we have a PewDiePie
Crossover Sayori suicide meme. We have memes about happiness goals and generic content, which makes you laugh
Ironic memes and edgy means sad and crippling depression memes everybody isn't that great?
Photographer takes a picture of students before and after telling them. I love you. We have Yuri which is cute
She's just timid, Monika gets happy
Natsuki of course, it's Natsuki and Sayori- goddamn it
Well, that's all the Christmas decorations up... only one more thing to hang D:
She's so cute
Which really elevates this meme so much - because of the Japanese influence that this?
Actually Western game has, we have of course that Blend S version of this meme
Suicide
Then we have my girl, my BAE if you pick any other girl, but Yuri. I'm sorry to say you are re- [ERROR]
That's not me being offensive  or
Hyperbolic, it's just straight-up facts. Yuri is the number one girl, and if you don't realize that then I have no other choice
But to say there must be something wrong with you. Oh look how cute
Manga is literature. Oh, no it's retarded.
We have Yuri which personal trait is the the fanatics of the knives so we have of course the moe meme.
I gotta tell you, this is pretty terrific. I don't know why this exists. I don't
Stop posting the fucking monkey haircut memes
this is my favorite meme out of probably all Doki Doki memes because we have the two-finger we have the pen and
we have the knife
It's a very subtle meme it's a very subtle meme, and I think a lot of you probably
Think you know what the me is, but you don't really unless you played Doki Doki that's right mom you
Don't understand this meme go just click away from the video
This is not for you mom, but last but not least we have the Monika memes just
Monika. And the Monika memes are probably the greatest. Let's have a look
Sayori is shit waifu
Just Monika well done
I wrote a blog post about that about why you hate video games, because this is what it does it appeals like the male fantasy
and like how much times designers probably put into like
Just Monika just Monika now there are so many Monika memes and in Sweden
In Sweden we have a song. I mention it in my Doki Doki playthrough, and it's probably one of the greatest songs ever written it
Basically just goes hey Monika. Hello. Hey on you Monika. Hey Monika. Hello on you Monika
Hey, Monika
hello on you Monica over and over and over this song makes gucci gang seems seem like a
Lyrical genius, okay, but the so- this song is so fucking catchy and since we have so many Monica means
I just thought well just put the Monika memes over this hey Monika song which should have been
Just Monika, just just Monika
Hey Hey Monika (hej hej monika)
Hey on you, Monika (hej på dig monika)
Hey, Monika (hej monika)
Cold eyes, Cold shivers (kalla blickar, kalla kårar)
You were only 14 years old (du va bara 14 vårar)
Take my hand, And show me the way (ta min hand, och visa mig vägen)
I'm yours, in every situation (Jag är din, i alla lägen)
Hey, hey, Monika (hej hej monika)
Hey on you Monika (hej på dig monika)
Hey, Monika (hej monika)
Hey on you, Monika (hej på dig monika)
Feels like our love was askew from the start (Känns som vår kärlek kom på sne från början)
Just like the leaning Tower of Pisa (Precis som lutande tornet i Pisa)
And that tower stands there to this day (Men tornet står där än idag)
And here you stand, and here I stand (och här står du och här står jag)
Hey hey, Monika (hej hej monika)
Hey on you, Monika (hej på dig monika)
Hey Monika, hey on you Monika (hej monika, hej på dig monika)
HAY, MONIKA
HAYONYOU
Monika
*Gasps for air*
HAYMONIKA
Hay-
Mon-
*Out of breath*
he's dead
oh frick
I'm gonna rate it a 7.5 explosion, please
The highest we've ever rated the Doki Doki meme
I mean any meme so far if anyone wants to make a website with a scoreboard where other people can vote as well
That would be great, depression undertones
Which always gives extra points because of its adaptability because of its normie protection
The cuteness contrast that it has the multiple characters of this meme it's a very strong
Very strong meme last meme
It's the Deaf stranding memes which I know what you're saying Felix. That's really not much of a meme, and I agree 100%
legendary game maker
Kojima is making
finally his own game without Konami and
Sony basically could just open the floodgates
and said hey you know what you can take how much money you want and do whatever the heck you want and
That is basically resulted in
one of the weirdest videos I have ever seen
People try and break down what the heck they just saw in this trailer
And what the game is about and it turns out not even the people working on the game has any idea
What the game is about no not no one knows what the meme is about here. You have the end animator saying again
I thought he was kidding, but I soon realized that Kojima was serious
Kojima, you are safe now my sweet child - whatever the hell that was
Me, I owe you my life. The trailer has so much information on in it
and there's just too much to break down and
We have a lot of questions on the previous trailer, but now we have even more questions
What in the world is happening?
Why is Norman Reedus
Having a baby inside his belly is he going to give birth to baby
How did baby ended up inside Norman and?
Which hole will baby come out of these are the questions
That fans are waiting for and I think I think this meme - the reason why I'm bringing up this meme is mainly
due to the fact that, get on board now
Okay, get on board on the memes now because this is just the beginning of what clearly if they pan out to be even more
Beautiful memes in the future as we go further along
Now I don't know about you, but I think the
video is pretty straightforward
Okay, you have these other world creatures that wants to kill the people right so they have the baby, and he's like ah shit
I've been discovered. He throws away the baby as soon as he realized he's been just discovered
And tried to kill himself, but he fails in the trailer
You can see people aging faster while being in this black gooey thickness or whatever
I think the baby is basically you moving your soul into the baby, which is why is doing the thumbs up?
Just like the guy did and the trailer before he died
And then the goo is used to age himself quicker does that make sense of course it does of course it does this meme
I'm giving a three, but it has a long.. so much potential that this could be a 7.5
Just like Doki Doki, so I'm urging you get on board now, and that was it for this week of MEME REVIEW
I want to thank all my family all my friends all my fans and all my dogs
Thank you guys so much for another episode. Let's get this on trending. MEME review everybody, meme review and a ~squad fam~
HEYHEHEYhuyehuyUMONIKAHHRHRHHAFEI bye